Ends June 30th.
>> Tucker: IT LOOKS LIKE THEY
CHILDREN'S BOOKS BY LAURA
LEFT-WING CULTURAL REVOLUTION
NOW IN PROGRESS.
IT LAURA INGLE WILDER'S AWARD TO
THE CHILDREN'S LITERATURE LEGACY
AWARD.
AND SHE IS THE AUTHOR OF LESSONS
FROM THE PRAIRIE AND SHE PLAYED
CASSANDRA INGALLS ON "LITTLE
HOUSE ON THE PRAIRIE" ON
SITUATED TO RESPOND.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS CHARGE,
I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND IT.
>> SO WHEN I WAS WRITING
"LESSONS FROM THE PRAIRIE" I
READ ALL OF THE BOOKS AND IT'S
THEY ARE RISKING LIFE AND LIMB
ON THE PRAIRIE JUST ALONGSIDE
THE MEN.
WOMEN ARE DESCRIBED AS WORKING
OUTSIDE THE HOME AND SELLING
THINGS.
THIS WAS WRITTEN BY A WOMAN AND
THEY SAY THE BOOK REPRESENTS
OUTDATED CULTURAL IDEAS.
I WAS LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
OTHER WINNERS ON THEIR LIST,
GROWING UP IN SLAVERY.
STORIES OF YOUNG SLAVES BEING
NOTIONS ABOUT WOMEN AS WELL
WHICH IS WHY WE READ THESE
CULTURE, WHERE WE CAME FROM,
MISTAKES WE'VE MADE IN THE PAST,
AND THIS IS A STRONG FEMALE
AUTHOR.
IT'S A LEAD FEMALE CHARACTER,
EVEN THE SHOW.
AND HOLLY WENT THEY HAD A LEAD
FEMALE CHARACTER.
THE "ME TOO" MOVEMENT IS, WOMEN
ARE GETTING A FAIR SHAKE.
THIS IS LIKE AN OLD WOMAN
PROJECT BASICALLY, IF YOU LOOK
AT LAURA INGALLS WILDER WRITING
ABOUT HER FAMILY COME ABOUT HER
MOTHER'S LIFE ON THE FRONTIER.
THEY DROPPED THE LOG ON HER LEG
AND SHE CONTINUES TO BUILD A
HOUSE WITH THE TWO OF THEM WITH
A BROKEN FOOT.
NOW THAT'S EQUAL RIGHTS.
MY CONCLUSION IS, THESE PEOPLE